hey guys Pete here this is gonna be my
10 things you might have missed video
for Twin Peaks the return part 17 which
was the first half of the season finale
of season 3 boiler warning if you're not
caught up to the end of the return
through the finale you're not gonna want
to watch this video because it's
certainly gonna mess things up and ruin
all of it for you so go ahead and watch
something else and come back when you
finish the series so a lot of
interesting stuff happened in part 17
and I think this was pretty universally
enjoyed whereas 18 was a little more
divisive as far as whether people liked
it or were frustrated by it so we're
gonna do this just like we've done all
them ten things videos and I'll do a
separate one for part 18 tomorrow the
first thing you might have missed was
the sound that we heard when Laura
disappears as Cooper is leading her to
the portal is actually the giant sound
let's say it's the giant sound because
it's the one we heard on the record
player whenever he's talking to coop in
the scene where you know he tells them
Richard and Linda for thirty two birds
with one stone
what exactly it means that this is that
sound isn't clear but it's interesting
to note since the only other time we've
heard it was at that scene where we
heard coop listen to it through the
gramophone we've certainly heard a lot
of background noises we've heard the one
that they hear in the Great Northern and
then the one we hear most of the time
that you know the creepy electrical
noises are the ones that we've come to
associate with the dark forces in our
story well I say that what it actually
means isn't clear because I think it's
probably pretty complicated one they're
walking towards the firemen's portal so
that was the intended outcome that she
would get taken to his lair or what we
consider to most likely be the White
Lodge but to the screaming that happens
right after the disappearance seems to
imply that something went wrong with
that plan and since we saw a Sarah
Palmer's character smashing Laura's
homecoming picture just before that it
seems that those two things were
connected to Judy speaking of Sarah that
brings us to the next thing you might
have missed in that scene there's quite
a few interesting
things that could slip by you on the
first watch first the orientation of
this scene in the timeline is confusing
if we look at these three scenes in a
straight line how they're presented we
see a flashback to Josie and Pete's
morning in reality where Laura doesn't
wash up on the shore wrapped in plastic
you know a timeline where she never dies
then we see Sarah take the photo and
start to smash it with the bottle then
the scene with Cooper leading Laura
through the woods happens so that could
be an indication that all three of those
things are happen concurrently but not
necessarily in the same reality or the
same dimension or the same timeline
anyways the first thing you might have
missed here is that the photo and Sarah
are in the season 3 timeline in other
words this is the house that we've seen
her sitting around in in the timeline
where Laura and Leland died when Laura
disappears in the next scene the
existence of that room as it is should
be affected the next thing you might
have missed here is that the picture
itself never really gets damaged as
she's smashing at it the frame is
obliterated including the glass but the
picture itself still looks fine it
should have been thrashed into little
pieces but that doesn't seem to happen
although it does start to loop like the
film starts to loop here during this so
it might not be a big deal but it's
interesting all the same as far as I'm
concerned another thing you might have
missed that I'm not a hundred percent I
wasn't able to test this or check this
yet but there did seem to be an emphasis
on the sound that we hear with Sarah
before she enters the room and grabs the
picture I couldn't put my finger on
anything exactly so it didn't stand out
to me as anything that I remembered but
I've read a couple different people in a
couple different places say that this is
the sound of Sarah whenever she was
wailing or moaning when she called
Leland at the Great Northern
in the original season one so like I
said I can't say that for sure I did
have an indication that there was
something that we're supposed to pick up
there and that's the best thing I've
read so far since we're talking about
the Palmer House the next thing you
might have missed was
what was showing on the firemen screen I
mentioned it in my recap but it's worth
another mention if you missed that video
during the time that evil coupe is
locked in the cage in the firemen's
theater we see the giant alter his path
so when mr. C enters the vortex he was
likely expecting to end up at the Palmer
House where he was planning on finding
Judi we see that we see the house on the
screen and the fireman swipes it across
to change it from there to outside the
Twin Peaks Sheriff's Department and when
evil coupe ends up there he says out
loud what is this so that leads me to
believe that judy is inside up or in
control of Sarah Palmer which I touched
on in my Judy video there was another
thing here that I'll mention but I don't
know I'm not a really big I wasn't
bowled over by it when I saw it on
Reddit there's a post that someone made
that whenever Jefferies shows that
symbol which was basically the al cave
symbol that breaks apart and turns into
the 8th predator posted that when it
breaks apart when it becomes the 8th
from the al cave symbol it sort of turns
into the number 708 which is the address
on the Palmer House hold the reason I
wasn't 100% bowled over by it is because
there's not much first of all there's
two little pieces there so one's a seven
and one's a back setback word seven and
the other thing is is that there's
really no other way that symbol could
break in you know what I mean like there
wasn't really manipulated anyway it just
literally breaks into pieces and then
turns into an eight depending on weight
or the way you look at it it could be
interesting or it could just be a lucky
coincidence so that's up to you guys
there another thing you might have
missed here and this scene was that
Phillip Jeffrey says it's slippery in
here so it's kind of interesting to
think that even though we've been
calling him a kettle or a teapot or
insert any other description you have
for what it is that Phillip Jeffries is
now it may just be that he's inside
there so that's something to think about
the next thing is a callback that
probably nobody missed but if you
haven't rewatched the original run
recently I think the con
X's interesting when Mike meets Dale
after he passes through the door in the
basement of the Great Northern he
repeats a phrase we've heard before he
says through the darkness of Future past
the magician longs to see one chance out
between two worlds fire walk with me now
this came from season 2 episode 6 which
was titled demons that was an episode
that had a bunch of different
developments and we heard this for the
first time when Philip Gerard's meds
wear off at which point he changes to
the lodge personality Mike Mike can't or
won't say where bob is actually from
when coop asked him though Bob you know
he says what does Bob want Mike says
that Bob is eager for fun and to him
killing is fun he wears a smile and
everybody run he explains how Bob a sort
of a parasite and he is fueled by or
he's feeding on fear and pleasures but
that he needs a human host he reminds
scoop that he and Bob were together at
one time working together and you know
he lived above a convenience store until
Mike saw God or the face of God says the
poem it's interesting because coop
actually says it along with him and he
explains about how he saved himself
chopping off Phillip Gerard's arm and he
lays out that he you know he has one
purpose and that's to stop Bob and then
we also heard that raised the gifted in
the Damned whenever he talks about the
face of Bob is only his true face I
should say is only seen by the gifted or
the Damned so yeah and that ends the
episode you know after he tells them
that for nearly 40 years Bob's been
nearby and he describes a giant house
made of wood with differe hooves but all
alike and all inhabited by many
different souls each night the episode
then goes to the ending which is a shot
of the Great Northern with a red light
on it and it's kind of striking when you
think about it this has been one of the
most theorized phrases in the original
run of Twin Peaks right down to the
actual wording like the word chants
spelled CH a and
see e or CH a and TS and there's reasons
why both answers seem to be right so
yeah I don't want to go into that rabbit
hole but anyways this could just be a
whole nother video altogether however of
them one of my favorite theories I read
of this in the past was that this saying
comes you know fire walk with me comes
from a situation where you're trapped
but you have to make a deal with one of
these entities or something like a demon
which is the name of the title in order
to get out did the return bringing this
phrase back up bring any clarity really
not really not totally but it does give
us more to look at when we compare the
two different times mike has delivered
the phrase in the future of our
theorizing the next thing you might have
missed was it's 253 when Cooper looks at
the clock after asking Diane if she
remembers everything and she says yes
it's glitching between like 252 and 253
this little bit is fascinating for a
bunch of different reasons and there
could be a whole separate video on that
as well but what I feel is essential to
point out is this when Frank hawk and
Bobbie opened the tube for major Briggs
they found the note that led them to
jack rabbits palace and eventually got
Andy in front of the firemen the slip of
paper had two dates with the time 253
which I initially figured meant that
they would have to visit the same place
on two different days instead we see
that the time of the second date
referred directly to this moment there
was a piece of paper that had two
Cooper's and we saw the end the evil
Cooper when his body was transferred to
the Red Room after Dale put on the Al
Cave ring well he put it on him
obviously and we saw the return of Agent
Dale Cooper to the town of Twin Peaks
which is emphasized by Dianne saying the
one and only so the majority of what was
on that piece of paper has come to light
at this point the only parts that are
really not exactly clear are the moon
and the Sun and the image of what we
expect to be Judy above blue pine
mountain so theorize away on that one
the next thing you might have missed is
the wide shot of the characters
the return in the Twin Peaks Sheriff's
Department with all that happens in the
sequence that happens in Frank's office
this doesn't really stand out at first
but take a moment to soak this in look
at the characters I mean we have
characters old and new most of which
have played a large role in all of these
people in this lineup being here at this
moment if he had mixed feelings about
the return and especially the finality
take a long look at each one of these
characters and try to think of what your
favorite scene of theirs was this season
think about the last scene they were in
and how the earlier ones they were
involved with Gotham exactly to that
point it's pretty interesting and gosh
it's remarkable if you ask me there was
a post on Reddit where they sort of
mentioned each one of them from left to
right and described them and it's just
hilarious when you think about it
there's you know I suppose if there was
an entertaining amount of different
interactions between all these people
the last thing I'm going to talk about
today is one more trip into jail day
territory I made a whole video about
this so I won't go on too long about it
but there have been other theories that
have popped up since so I think it's
safe to say that the meaning of the
phrase jail day will continue to be a
mystery for quite some time when Gordon
explains Judy to Albert Tammy he
explains that the name came from what
used to be called jail day in olden
times most importantly he describes it
as an extreme negative force and that's
likely the best description we could
hope for what I mentioned in that video
where there were two prevailing ideas
that were going around was the most
popular by a lot being that jail day was
translated from Chinese to mean to
explain if you change the spelling up a
little bit you get a translation that
means to screen so those are the two
there's other ones that have popped up
which I don't really need to go all the
way into but what's somewhat hilarious
about the explained definition is that
if it's right then we'll probably never
know any more about it like it just ends
the explanation ends here while we might
get some nuggets out of Mark frost when
the final
ah see a comes out in relation to the
blue rose task force Lynch himself
already went pretty far to explain what
Judy is so expecting more information
would be dreaming so you guys can tell
me in the comments what your favorite
one is or if you think it doesn't mean
any his things that he just said that
because it was funny and he had to make
up something as a backstory for Judy so
there you have it ten things you might
have missed there were certainly more
these were the ones I think that I
wanted to point out because they lead us
into other discussion later it was
really action-packed there was a lot of
stuff that was resolved and you got to
admit it was pretty awesome to see that
old footage where Josie just continues
to get ready in the morning and Pete
walks right down and starts to fish as
if nothing's going on and you know I
mean it was a nice touch I think the
scene where Cooper and Diane kissed was
really kind of great as well like it was
unexpected in so many different ways a
lot of people guess that Diane might be
NIDA but the reveal was very exciting
because as you know no one all the
theories that have existed you know more
often than not have turned out to be
completely off base so if you think
about how long we wondered about who he
was talking to in that tape recorder and
you go back through the season and
realize that they weren't that close or
they weren't close in that way before he
disappeared so that kiss and that
question of do you remember everything I
mean that's related to something that's
happened in his time away he could have
been visiting her and her dreams he
could have had other alternate timelines
that ended different ways you know what
I mean there's just a lot of different
things that could actually make sense
there the amount of questions that it
brings up is just amazing we'll have to
get into those into the future but with
you know it's not really within the
scope of this video and you know there's
just so much to think about so much to
talk about if you've only watched it
once I can tell you from my own
experience that it kind of gets better
every Epis
once the big reveals are out of the way
once you know what's coming you pick up
on a lot more details and it's just
really fantastic so we'll be watching
this and re watching this for years to
come I have a feeling so one more of
these tomorrow and then we'll make some
other stuff but yeah
part 18 tomorrow that's my plan I got a
book giveaway over on my patreon account
so make sure you follow the link and go
check that out it's growing pretty well
so I want to thank those of you who
signed up already
now the define our videos are winding up
we'll get into some more stuff and
figure out where we're gonna go yeah but
think about it and think about coming
over there and joining the community and
I would really appreciate it so that I
can get a new mic and do all these
things that I need to do in order to
make the best Twin Peaks videos I can
make sure you like this video if you
enjoyed it make sure you subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already turn on
notifications and make sure you follow
me on my social media accounts
Twitter's where I'm at most of the time
but you can find me on Instagram and
Facebook as well thanks for watching
guys I'll talk to you soon